وسانجاي مع تلقي المزيد من الأشخاص للتطعيم
200 مليون
حقنة حتى الآن ما نصيحتك لأولئك
الذين يشعرون بالقلق بشأن
الأعراض المحتملة من اللقاح ، لقد عانيت أنت وأنا من
بعض
الأعراض البسيطة نسبيًا منذ أن
حصلنا على التطعيم في
حالة تناول الأشخاص المسكنات قبل
أن يتم تطعيمهم
بعد تلقيح معين  المشروبات لتحافظ على رطوبتك ،
ما رأيك ،
نعم ، لا أعتقد أنك تتناول
المسكنات قبل سببين أحدهما هو
أنك قد لا تحتاجها ،
فلماذا تتناولها وإذا كنت من كبار
السن ، فقد يكون من المخاطرة
فعلاً تناولها  بعض مسكنات الألم هذه ، ولكن
إذا كنت بحاجة إليها بعد ذلك ، فيمكنك تناولها ،
والسبب الثاني لعدم تناولها من قبل
هو في جزء منه
أنك تعطي اللقاح
وتحفز هذه
الاستجابة الالتهابية بشكل أساسي إذا أعطيت مضادات الالتهاب
في وقت مبكر ، فقد تضعف  هذه
الاستجابة قليلاً
حتى تعرف مرة أخرى إذا كنت تعاني من
أعراض كبيرة ، فتناولها بعد
الكثير من السوائل وأنت تعلم أيضًا أن
الناس سيحصلون على نوع من هذا في بعض
الأحيان  قد تكون سمعت عن ذراع أو ذراع مرغوب
فيه ويمكن أن تبدو مثيرة جدًا
لمضادات الهيستامين يمكن أن تساعد في ذلك إذا كان
لديك ذراع مرغوب فيه في ذراع واحدة في
المرة الأولى التي قد ترغب فيها في طلب الحصول
على الحقنة في الذراع الأخرى ،
لذا فإن أشياء من هذا القبيل  لكن الأعراض
جميلة ذاتية الشفاء